inflation in the united states is at a
40-year high and one of the questions
that people have is how the hell did we
get here of course our politicians
there's lots of eroding trust in many of
the institutions including those elected
officials but now they are absolutely
just gaslighting the american people
what do i mean well here's a recent
speech from joe biden where he says some
pretty crazy things let's listen to it
so i'm sick of this stuff
we have to talk about it because the
american people think the reason for
inflation is government spending more
money simply not true
well i don't know about you but i took
an economics 101 class and if they print
a lot of money it drives consumer prices
up and so ultimately that leads to
inflation so maybe he took a different
economic class than i did but i'm pretty
sure that government spending and the
printing of more money leads to
inflation but maybe they don't actually
believe what they're saying because joe
biden also said a large contributor to
inflation this month was an increase in
gas and energy prices as markets reacted
to putin's aggressive actions now the
last inflation number we have is from
february of 2022 putin didn't actually
invade ukraine until the end about three
or four days before the end of the month
and then continued his actions in march
so unless the inflation numbers can
somehow tell the future the inflation
numbers are representing a time before
the invasion of ukraine this is all
absurd and ultimately exactly what
you're thinking at home is true if we go
ahead and we look at the growth of the
m1 money supply what we can see you see
over there on the far right that massive
inflection point in 2020 that was the
creation of new money and when they
injected trillions and trillions of
dollars into the global economy guess
what happened friends about 12 months
later inflation exploded and so we can
see here in this chart that as that
inflation exploded at the end of 2020
into 2021 and then into 2022 there's
only one culprit to blame it's the fact
that we decided to put interest rates at
zero percent and that we printed
trillions of dollars and injected it
into the economy no one believes the
economist the mainstream media or the
politicians everyone can see it we can
all feel it 7.9 maybe the official
inflation number the unofficial real
number for most people in the united
states is much higher and ultimately we
all know exactly what happened they
devalued the currency and they're
offloading the cost of doing it to the
people at the bottom of our economy and
of society who hold no investable assets
make sure you get educated stop
listening to these people and make sure
you're protecting yourself from what
likely is higher and higher inflation in
the future hey you did you like this
video great we make five of them a day
and post them here on this channel make
sure you subscribe like the video and
see you next time